the Joe Rogan experience actually I
gotta say this I the best compliment I
was ever given I put up a post and it
was me drinking coffee in the morning
just naked but like from like the hip up
and somebody gave me a compliment that's
actually comes from something you said
they said damn Roberts got a really good
dick root I think I invented dick root
dick cruise when those dudes I don't
understand what dudes do that they wear
their shorts so low that you basically
see the top of their [ __ ] see the root
but I've got nothing else to show so
that's a weird weird move if you feel a
little dick root that's all it comes up
on the dick root bro it's just a weird
thing I mean when did guys start doing I
get girls doing it I get it right I just
don't get guys pulling their shorts all
the way down low like that seems like
you're just asking to get pantsed like I
don't understand like sagging I guess it
like it comes out of prison culture from
what I heard but I hate it now but I
feel like an old man because I used to
do it as a kid used to sag well I grew
up in an area it was like it was a very
low income like area I don't know how to
say that politically correct so uh like
everybody was sagging the end like boxer
shorts under no yes we have to you
learned see when you start off with
tighty whiteys and then everyone makes
funnier than you like oh right so you
switch to boxes well weird like style
yeah I ran out of that by the time I was
like 12 though like this is ridiculous
well my problem is like if somebody like
grabs your pants like you're done like
you're gonna have to reach for your
pants and then they're gonna punch you
in the face like this is a tech you're
like asking you're you're like at a
handicap yeah you sound exactly like my
father right now exactly what do you
would say you're gonna get your ass
kicked
yeah I have friends that tried it like
even 10-15 years ago what guys my age I
was like wow the [ __ ] are you doing
that's still they don't the thing now is
skinny jeans and sagging
which is like a counterproductive away
it just doesn't seem like it goes
together right there trying to combine
styles and understand what they're doing
right yeah well I mean if they've got a
good enough dick route then maybe that's
what it is
[Applause]